hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zum pvp am abend mit
lukaku soll jetzt keine neue serie
werden oder so aber mir ist einfach
nicht anders kann eingefallen das
einzige was ich quasi sagen wollte in
diesem video war dass ich spaß habe und
es war
nein also ich hab jetzt gedacht ich bin
ja gerade wenn ihr das video seht in
berlin da werden auch noch ein paar
videos da werde ich auch noch ein
bisschen was aufnehmen weil ich damit
anderen youtube wie beispielsweise kran
crafter oder paletten oder pixel golf
oder opel oder regenzeit und noch ein
paar andere werden da sein weil wir da
so ein bisschen was erledigen müssen was
plant für die zukunft so ein paar coole
sachen die euch noch erwarten deswegen
bin ich ihr garten bisher produzieren
und ich dachte mir was kann ich denn was
macht deine letzter zeit nicht so viel
spaß wie bett wars richtig gar nichts
etwas finde ich einfach richtig richtig
cool ist ein richtig cooler modus spiele
ich privat schon sehr lange aber ich und
habe ich noch nie aufgenommen dann
gesehen dass er bergmann soll es also
ich glaube ich muss jetzt gar keine
vorgeschichte zu erzähle ich aber selber
schon manchmal etwas hochgeladen haben
leider das jetzt leider ich hab jetzt
gedacht ich nehme das ganz alleine auf
weil ich ein thema ansprechen konnte
wollte wo keiner so wirklich was heißt
mitreden kann wo keiner so wirklich ja
doch mitreden kann und zwar geht es um
eine t shirt und wenn ich jetzt dass mit
ihnen dem anderen machen würde der wird
dann quasi nur so sagen ja stimmt so
holding ag bronze da und das eisen und
macht man dies und dies blabla erfolge
kronleuchter gesprungen
ich würde sagen wir gehen erst mal ganz
kurz erst mal wenn ihr das video nicht
so lange schauen wollten einfach nur
gelesen habe im titel steht der hat t
shirts dann guckt einfach in die
beschreibung unter findet ihr irgendwo
ganz oben in den ersten drei zeilen
findet ihr links shirts und dann könnt
ihr darauf klickt und dann kann die nati
shirts von mir bestellen so alles
weitere zu den t shirts was für designs
gibt was das findest vorgeschichte war
warum ich diese designs genommen habe
und und und sag ich jetzt alles in
diesem video
wenn ihr freunde habt ihr auch eventuell
schon mal gesagt haben auch mal der
könnte doch umweltschützer machen dann
könnt ihr das sehen einfach zeigen oder
einfach den shop weiter senden muss ja
nicht jeder gleich dieses langweilige
video von mir anschauen wir machen jetzt
erst mal irgendeine rund 20 gerne einem
viererteam sein und vier mal vier
spielen
ich bin schon oft in die ddr
sven 75 kulas gm ist echt cool so wir
manchmal aber ganz gut spieler versteckt
damit ich in der lobby ihr einkommen
derjenigen weg so wir gehen einfach mal
skybridge habe jetzt noch nicht gespielt
wir gehen jetzt einfach mal hier rein
und ich weiß nicht in welchem team ich
bin ich bin blau so wie es aussieht was
ist das denn für ein web
ich hab die map noch nie gespielt ich
weiß nicht wie also eigentlich ist es ja
egal was uns für eine map ist aber ich
bin echt nicht sicher na gut
sky wird kann ich nicht aber gut was ich
sagen wollte wenn ich mir hier schon die
branche ein bisschen schnappe ist dass
ich einen t shirt shop habe ich bin ja
jetzt wahrscheinlich wenn ihr das video
seht ich kann es ja schon mal sagen ich
bin jetzt bei die wehmut aber auch da
hab ich hab ich nicht ich bin ja jetzt
bei die lüfte partner ich dachte dass
man einfach schon mal weil es so sein
wird weil von anderen netzwerken wo
andere youtuber sind die ich kenne hört
man nur schlecht ist und von denen da
kenne ich die leute ganz gut dass max
drin also einer meiner besten freunde
einfach mal runter gefallen ich sagt er
wird ein bisschen weiter noch also ich
bin jetzt bei denim ufern hat das über
die alles gemacht und blablabla die
haben dabei auch ein bisschen geholfen
also die designs habe ich komplett
selber gemacht aber die wird durch
komplette über gehöriger soll der zu
klingen aber um maniche wärt ihr habt es
wieder alles falsch verstanden und
meckert jetzt wieder nur um viele leute
sind in letzter zeit da meckern aber
dazu in einer anderen figur
jedenfalls sind die sind eh viel viel
schneller am gold also wieso geht denn
unser typ da einfach mal nach unten
wieso lässt sich dann einfach
runterfallen
dann kann er schreiben habe keine blöcke
mehr fallen nach unten wenn ich da nicht
einmal den weg baut
ach ja gut jedenfalls sind viele freunde
von mir bei diesen rufen die leute sind
mir mega sympathisch und die kombi
entgegen weil fragen etc und alles
möglich also relativ cool eigentlich
alles was die da machen was ist das
jetzt hier auch hier wird es hier wird
es gold gedroppt also ok auch gut statt
jetzt einfach mal bisschen dahin kommt
dann kann ich ihn vielleicht ein
bisschen überreichen die wiking boxteam
dropped jetzt auch noch mal gold
eigentlich möchte ich nur drei gold mir
das 1 er ist ein gold noch was noch was
bitte
du darfst den blogs hans lanz dorn nicht
setzen
diese stehen in wenigen sätzen
normalerweise egal ob die map
wahrscheinlich alle schon total auf
gespielt und will ist das schon und ich
bin ihr wieder ein totaler kacken dafür
entschuldige ich mich ich bin ich gut
jedenfalls den ich jetzt bei den buben
habe das mit denen so ein bisschen
durchgeplant wie wir das machen mit bei
mir im team das bei mir im team
wie wird es machen mit ist er bei mir
und ihm ja ich glaube schon
wie wird es machen mit danke kollege wie
wir das machen mit den sachen mit den
designs und blau und dann haben wir das
mit dem bisschen durchgesprochen und es
gibt schon sehr coole designs die ich
mir da überlegt habe die ich designt
habe und die im shop jetzt verfügbar
sind und zwar hab ich mir immer so
gedacht im gegensatz zu allen anderen
youtube ich möchte halt einerseits dass
das shirt design dass ihr damit ein
bisschen mit mir quasi verbunden seid
also dass wir sagen können hey komm ich
habe jetzt dieses shirt und also es gibt
ich fange mal mit den designs an es gibt
bisher einmal ein schriftzug also con in
schreibschrift und neben das bett so
häufig so wo ist denn unser bett wenn
ich das wüsste dass auch noch mal geil
ach da einmal dieses unseren konz
schriftzug in schreibschrift und dann
noch einmal aneinander eine ananas
und diese an als extra schlecht gepixelt
latschen da unten doch da ist einer dem
man denn ich in unserem team ist box
jedoch box ihn doch er trifft einfach
nicht starker typ so ich hole mir
endlich etwas für meine sachen das bild
vom team wurde zerstört
wieso wurde denn unser bett zerstört
geil geil hier oben passt so ein typ auf
und der kriegt einfach nicht mit oder
wie mein gott ich habe immer so ein pech
mit den teams na ja gut ich habe keinen
bock den hut vor meinen sachen abzugeben
wenn die da die kriegen ja nix
geschissen hier so ich habe jetzt hier
erstmal noch so ein bisschen rüstung
wird wahrscheinlich gleich von hinten
den etat gewechselten gemetzelt weil er
keine aufpasst aber naja jetzt ist ja
nur ein spiel freunde bitten uns zu
retten
das rät die restlichen sachen packt man
eben einfach in die kiste der chronik
noch knüppel mit rückstoß und fressen
schon mal was jedenfalls trotzdem alle
noch überlebt ja wir können aber nicht
mehr respawnen blödmann frauen
jedenfalls ich weiß gar nicht was ich
aber freunde das tut mir total leid
wahrscheinlich sterbe ich jetzt
vielleicht direkt ich gehe jetzt erstmal
ganz kurzen macht ihm ein thema zu ende
und zwar hab ich halt gedacht ich mache
einen design und ich mache ein paar
designs wo er einerseits sagen könnt ok
komponist er von kontraste damit seid
ihr quasi so ein bisschen das kennt er
und diese ananas ist etwas durch also
meine haare war ja damals oder jetzt
immer noch quasi wie so eine ananas
aufgebaut meinten viele leute ich weiß
nicht ich weiß eben eine friseurin ist
relativ kurz
aber das meinte halt relativ viele und
deswegen habe ich gerade mal neun
anderen das design
ich hab mir selber schon shirts bestellt
in grau mit dem weißen schriftzug kommen
drauf und in navy farben mit einer
ananas drauf bin ich sehr sehr cool und
dann hab ich jetzt halt quasi gedacht
okay diese beiden ich möchte nicht
einfach nur con kräfte auf den open days
draufpacken wisst ihr das ist halt ein
bisschen ärgert die dominieren die mitte
da vollkommen ich möchte nicht einfach
so kontraste auf t shirt draufpacken
weil ich bin es ein bisschen so nicht
eingebildet aber sonja doch einerseits
ein bisschen eingebildet und
andererseits auch so ein bisschen nicht
schön also ich finde es nicht schön wenn
man einfach nur den namen und ein
kreatives passende wort ich find's
einfach so weit so jung
ihr habt ein t shirt von kontraste an da
steht nur kontrast darauf weil das ist
der youtuber von dem das gemacht ist
deswegen auch nicht immer einfach
content schreibschrift aber ist kein
okay korn was ist konnten was ist das
und es sieht ja trotzdem cool aus und
ist mit der alte ist ein bisschen wie
diese hype t shirts dir wahrscheinlich
kennt die daten wie zum beispiel
rangenommen die sind relativ dieser auf
total cool ist auch total alles
abgesichert und so also dass daran habe
ich mich so ein bisschen orientiert und
mit der ananas halt einfach wegen der
anderen das finde ich auch ganz cool
anders finde ich am besten mit navy blau
als t shirt und es gibt aber nicht nur t
shirt sondern es gibt auch pullover und
longsleeves und
mit v ausschnitt und noch ganz viele
andere sachen und auch für frauen und
baseball shirts und alles und da steht
einfach eine einer mitte der die
krassesten sachen hat er könne jetzt
quasi gar nicht hin er hat schon bogen
der pixma kollege mensch bruder ist ein
los mit dir
soll ich nehmen wir das eisen daraus
eine spitzhacke könnte ich mir nicht
auch noch machen so eine spitzhacke wir
haben jetzt wird es quasi nicht mehr
response jetzt hab ich hab noch nie so
viel bronx auf einem ort gesehen
ich brauche es kreisen ich muss auf die
reisen bekommen und ich mir bessere
brüstung platte danach bin ich denke ich
mit dem thema gerne mit und lass mir
wieder umbringen oder versucht so viel
zu heiß wie geht jedenfalls das einzige
was ich sagen wollte ihr findet in der
beschreibung einen link und auf diesen
link könnt ihr draufklicken und der rest
liegt bei euch dann habt ihr quasi alle
sachen das ist dann sind dann die t
shirts aufgelöst als mögliche kunst
bestellen das ist fair trade das ist
alles super dass es meistens 100 prozent
baumwolle sowie also man schnitzler drin
irgendwie nicht und keine ahnung also
das ist alles richtig richtig cool
eigentlich noch ein eisen bitte bruder
und wie gesagt klickt einfach auf den
link oder beschreibungen er wolle
eigentlich gar nicht sagen wenn ihr t
shirts haben wollte weil ich finds
richtig cool wenn dann irgendwann bei
twitter ihr könnt mir bei twitter folgen
müsste ich könnt ihr aber und da könnt
ihr dann einfach mal da kann man ja auch
schon erschießen da kann man ja auch
bilder hochladen bei twitter
er lag schon 1 schade da kann man bilder
hochladen bei twitter und über diese
bilder könnt ihr mir glaube ich noch
sonst schnell geändert die trinker
genannt und über diese bilder könnt ihr
wenn bei twitter einfach den hashtag
hash text abgeben das heißt er hat quasi
sein t-shirt jetzt bestellt sagen wir
mal gucken hat das video denkt ja kommen
ich gebe auf die seite geht mal drauf
dann seht ihr die t-shirts und china
konnte denke das sieht ganz keck on höhe
das sieht jetzt cool aus bestellt mal
so'n t-shirt habt es dann bestellt es
kommt euch zu hause an und dann könnt
ihr einfach bei twitter seien bild
posten hey guck mal luca hier ich hab
hier so'n t shirt gekauft hashtag
konnten kräfte und stoff einfach so
stuff ist also sachen klamotten dinge
also konstanz ursachen von con und
ein eisen noch kollege und dann könnt
ihr das hier einfach mal twittern und
dann retreat ich das wenn ich das dann
sähe und alles möglich also wenn ich auf
jeden fall cool da bilder zu sehen
wenn ich auf jeden fall cool bilder zu
sehen wenn ihr die sachen an habt und so
das find ich auf jeden fall richtig
richtig cool und ich freue mich einfach
ich würde mich total freuen über
kommentare ob ihr das cool findet ich
laufe jetzt einfach in die mitte
ich habe drei minuten des wegen seiner
noch kurzen abschluss deswegen schreibt
eure meinung dazu eine kommentare
zunächst eventuell auch andere designs
bessere design schöne designs könnt ihr
mir alles zukommen lassen und sonst
würde ich sagen ach ja was ich noch
sagen wollte ich habe jetzt nicht ich
hab jetzt kein shirt an
das geht nämlich gerade noch nicht weil
der shop ist gerade mal zwei stunden
online wenn ich dieses video aufnehmen
und deswegen ich habe mir schon selber
shirts bestellt und wenn meine shirts da
sind kommen videos kommt ein video zu
den shirts also wie ich dann als an habe
und dann präsentiere ich euch das auch
noch mal wie es denn aussieht wenn ich
das an habe und so kommt dann auf meinem
kanal
das heißt ich habe quasi jetzt selber
schon ein paar sachen bestellt auch für
meine mutter die fand die designs auch
ganz cool und hab dann schon ein paar
sachen bestellt und wenn die sachen an
da sind dann kommt irgendwie in der
woche oder so weil ich bin ja selber
noch in berlin jetzt gerade wenn ihr das
video seht wenn ich dann wieder zu hause
bin
kommt dann ein video dazu wie ich die
sachen an habe und wie das ganze
aussieht damit ihr dann selber noch mal
nicht nur über die website sehen können
sondern noch mal so ein echt sehen könnt
ok kommen so sieht es also aus wenn der
lukas in echt anhalt und das sieht ja
voll cool aus und blablabla des eda so
ein bisschen sehen können wie das ganze
dann in real life quasi aussieht und da
freue ich mich auf jeden fall auch schon
darauf wenn die sache da sind und dann
kann ich euch das ganze nochmal
präsentieren das heißt wenn ihr euch
jetzt noch ein bisschen und schließlich
seid und so sagt okay ich bin mir nicht
sicher wie bieten das ganze aus nicht
nur so auf der website sondern so ein
natura dann wartet einfach ab und in ein
paar tagen oder in einer woche
allerspätestens kommt dann noch mal ein
video dazu
der typ sollte ein grund dass gold holen
und nicht die ganze zeit herum könnten
ja nicht treffen hatte das gold holte
das ich weiß nicht erholt ist gar nicht
so du jetzt mal weg jetzt
videofunktion ein rückschluss scheiße
ich als nicht gehen beginnende
vielleicht nicht so gut mit
kuckuck ihr könnt ihr einfach mal also
wirklich ich möchte jetzt nicht so ein
blödes würde es marketing hier betreiben
und euch die ganze zeit sein cook durch
die shirts an also es ist eure sache
wenn jetzt bestellen wollte dann könnte
es bestellen und wenn ich dann lasst es
alter wiederholten hier
der typ hat auch ein bisschen ausländer
verzieh dich du opfer ja wieso holt denn
hier keiner das gold das regt mich so
ein bisschen auf ich verstecke mich
jetzt eventuell kommt er ja wohl doch
einer das gold von unserem team
ich verstehe nicht was unser team macht
da unten ist ja auch keiner von unseren
leuten download wahrscheinlich sieht man
sogar dass ich hier so ein bisschen
leute erst wieder tot
gott jetzt hat auch noch ein bogen
ausgepackt ich glaube ich werde nie mehr
jungs holt doch das gold verteidige hier
die ganze zeit
oder sind die alle schon tot aus unserem
team
ich bin ich gleich selber tot
da ist jetzt noch schnell was ich habe
nicht mal so ein heilungs trank ein
bisschen doof da kommt auch keiner die
ich die weiße unsere leute die killen da
hinten rum
ja was für gut so kommt doch einfach mal
selber hier an ich bin gleich selber tot
ich kann ja nichts mehr machen hier
ich muss jetzt selber ab und jetzt werde
ich 100-prozentig jeden moment
abgeschossen
jetzt werde ich gleich abgeschossen da
bin ich selber tot und meine leute jetzt
guckt jetzt noch mal nachdenken
ich hatte gerade locker ich standard
locker vier minuten rum und hat die
ganze zeit verteidigt in vehrte gold
holen können und was machen die hier die
lümmel hier hinten rum er er denkt zu jo
ich ziehe man von hier richtig manöver
sind denn für leute also etwas muss man
immer irgendwie mit anderen leuten
spielen gut jetzt liegt hier noch ein
bisschen gold also ich hätte die runde
noch so lange durchhalten hoffe ich mal
wie das irgendwie geht nutzte trinken
sie vor tätig griffig schärfen und
concord jetzt schießen sie auch hier
schon doch in der strom- sentiert sein
gold ja aber heute sind wir die einzigen
da wir sind die einzigen die noch leben
ich glaube schachten gut habe ich um
einen bogen alter ich gebe jetzt einfach
13 gold für sein bogen aus war aber er
hat ja schon
ich hab mich tief mehr bekommen als ich
hab den krassesten bogen den skript eine
rüstung ist ein bisschen angeschlagen
aber ich glaube gleich wenn ich fertig
bin da gehe ich auf jeden fall wieder da
hinten hin
ich hab keinen bock dass die mir hier
irgendwie dass dieses andere team es ist
ja nur noch von von grüner seiner noch
einer niemals aufgeben niemals
kapitulieren
genau für sparte
wir sind einfach ohne spaß und sabet
wird halt wirklich als erstes abgebaut
und wir leben halt wirklich immer noch
so ich werde das jetzt hin
nimm das und wir gehen zusammen in die
netapp so hier jetzt trinken wir diese
scheiß und laufen drüber schade dass man
ja jetzt werde ich auch noch
abgeschossen
so kommen weiter
los los los los los los hätte ich von da
wieder abgeschossen
wir müssen halt wirklich wert sind so
ein bisschen taktisch das ist eine sehr
spannende runde gefällt mir sehr
ja er ist tot jetzt schnell weiter
vorschnell weiter vor direkt in die
mitte ich weiß gar nicht warum ich rede
und mit wem ich grad rede aber ich bin
halt einfach voll in dieser runde drin
weil wir beiden dass hier noch richtig
gut reißen die beiden vom team blau
ich habe jetzt gar ich hab voll wenig
blöcke mitgenommen das ist jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen eine blöde
entscheidung gewesen aber er hat wäre
ich okay gut
baumann die blogger plumpe ich weiß gar
nicht wie ich mit diesem pixar rede
er ist tot zu rot okay jetzt absolut so
wir haben noch einen eineinhalb minuten
schnelligkeit die haben dahin
wahrscheinlich schon wieder die nächsten
der erste abschnitt haben wir hinten
auch schon wieder so einen bogen und
pfeile kako alter hut richtig angst ich
habe richtig angst hat auch richtig
wenig leben
ich muss auf jeden fall noch mal zurück
der schon wieder tot da hinten
er muss jetzt auf jeden fall bisschen
folgen ist ein bisschen blöd dass ich
bin alleine
naja gut was soll ich da machen
ich bin ich gut im pvp und ich war
alleine am ende noch und auch keine
ahnung ich finde die haben uns gut
gehalten also ein kompliment an pigs man
dass wir beide das zusammen so gut
gemacht haben obwohl wenig am skypen
waren ein bisschen traurig dass jetzt
doch noch verloren hab ich dachte wir
reißen das eigentlich noch weil einfach
nur noch team rot und einer von grün am
leben war der von grün kann eh nix mehr
reißen der verkämpft sich wahrscheinlich
daran irgendwo ist ein grün das ist doch
geld oder die das grün
schauen wir mal eben bei grüne oder ist
der typ der verkämpft sich da an seiner
mit dem bogen der wird das spiel
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen hinauszögern
was ich eigentlich sagen wollte in
dieser runde war grundsätzlich das thema
das ich jetzt hier schütz habt ihr könnt
euch in der beschreibung einfach
angucken ich möchte es nicht sagen ja
auf t shirts nur ich finde die school
deswegen macht einfach gerne werbung
ihr könnt einfach in der beschreibung
anklicken ich verdiene durch diese teil
auch nicht fehlen ich finde diese zeit
wirklich cool und ich find's cool wenn
wir so ein bisschen soweit aufbauen
sodass ihr staatsvertrag bla bla bla und
dass wir dann so ein bisschen so
interagieren über die bedachte und so
also in der beschreibung 20 minuten
schon wieder in einer beschreibung könnt
ihr einfach auf den link draufklicken
könnte irgendwas bestellen wenn ihr
wollt und
das einzige was zu sagen ist es dass es
ja auch diesen code gibt mit dem man das
ganze ein bisschen günstiger bekommt der
steht aber auch in der beschreibung und
ja ich würde mich auf jeden fall freuen
wenn ihr einfach mal vorbeischaut und
ich wollte noch irgendwas sagen aber ich
hab's vergessen egal ich bin jetzt auf
jeden fall wenn das video seht in berlin
und dazu ja der von runtergefallen bin
ich gerade in berlin und ihr bekommt
dann wahrscheinlich auch eine tour von
berlin wenn ich das dann machen darf und
alles mögliche da werden auf jeden fall
ganz coole sachen kommen ich wollte nur
sagen dass die shirts hat und in einer
woche wenn ich selber meine chance
kommen einmal ein richtiges video wo ich
die sachen dann auch an haben und euch
zeigen kann und blabla das gerade auf
dem feld ist nur bearbeitet und dann
würde ich sagen ich wünsche mir selber
viel spaß in berlin
und wir sehen uns dann in folgenden
videos